I think people talk a big game that they
want to build a hundred million dollar
company
but aren't willing to do the sacrifices
nor should they if one isn't passionate
enough or happy enough to sacrifice golf
or family time or leisure then they
shouldn't but I think it's I think focus
is I'm running out of time or focus is
the great entrepreneurial excuse for my
actions don't match my ambitions this
portion is like with me so I think this
is one you need to get selfish like
you'd ask your question
[Music]
hiring is guessing firing as well like
you gotta go fast that's how you get
[ __ ] done that's a bigger step out this
is the television and the television is
the radio before these [ __ ] so
my question is and I started took away
already a lot of information from what
we've been talking about all day is that
so I have a ton of content that I can
create and I feel sort of mired in the
inability to sort of ferret out like how
to organize the content and start
delivering because it's across not only
just one problem that people are having
but like if you look at a woman's entire
reproductive life cycle I have 20 years
of clinical experience I work with over
10,000 women so it's like volumes of
content to be creating in PMS cramping
menopause pregnancy infertility and I
can't decide like should I just focus in
on one zone there so go ahead let you
answer well I'm just jumping on that one
because it's so easy I'll let you keep
talking but the answer is of course not
because as you know that just then
limits you to that narrow of a thing but
the whole punch line of this whole thing
and I'm sure for a lot of you is driving
down the cost of creative and that is
not just having the ability to produce
creative at a cost that you can afford
it actually starts with your own
subjective opinion about the creative
it's the biggest reason everyone's
losing you're judging it before it hits
the day of light in your own eco chamber
the end I have no idea how well my posts
are gonna do I have hypothesis
I have intuition I like debating with my
own self out of how good am I at knowing
the current state of my audience or
potential audience but on a daily basis
I'm surprised on upside and downside of
pieces of content its humility it's
actually respecting your customer more
than your own opinion egos just
insecurities in makeup the end like
what's so crazy about this little three
minutes already is how unmotivated I am
for anything else to talk about like how
I very much feel that for
majority of your businesses I'm just
answering the actual question cuz now
what happens and sensing the moment with
the the seven of us is if you can
actually believe that well then you can
imagine how much time you spend on
completely different things which leads
to actually making what I figured out
and why the garyvee content model was
such a big hit when I put it out is cool
first I needed the reactions that I just
got second now you decide how do you
build the most efficient infrastructure
to extract the most content down it's
why it's why I want people to build
podcasts let me explain why I think
podcasts is a triple arbitrage one you
get the podcast and people are listening
in the world today to you film the
podcast which gives you an ungodly
amount of post production capabilities
to me I mean you guys are most likely
here because you're aware of me this is
how you became aware of me you know the
post production capabilities of that
filming give you three four seven twelve
yet one motherlode pod you know piece of
content for your YouTube and Facebook
video you could then get the potential
have six to nineteen pieces of other
content that come from a moment or two
and then the third arbitrage and that's
ripple arbitrage is you've guessed I'm
doing something right now that's super
interesting literally in the last two
days I've posted a question for Mark
Cuban and yesterday I posted a question
from Shawn Mendes is that right that's
awesome so you know it's it's working
and they both neither question was so I
mean Cubans for sure was super narrow
for instagrams they're not hiring that's
linked in more than Instagram Shawn's
question was a little more passionate a
little bit more networks but both over
indexed and both over a million views on
Instagram which is a high watermark for
me because they have brand equity so you
can imagine you know this is why they
ask you know I I know you guys have
heard this watch what I'm doing not what
I'm saying the askgaryvee show was a
quick early tell
of how smart I understood this I started
a Q&A show because I didn't have to do
anything to create the content the
content was I was put on third and a
half base I just had a feel I leaned in
my self awareness that I understand what
I'm talking about in my world and I'm
quick to think and I can do it every day
somebody walked in and asked me four
questions I just answered them the
questions were happening on Twitter
which inherently created more awareness
of me because people saw people asking
me questions so I'm very good at Easter
I'm going I'm very good at creating
frameworks which led me to what ended up
being the holy grail of I'm gonna just
[ __ ] fill myself as often as humanly
possible and post produce you want to
get real crazy I apologize I've never
said this out loud this entire program
was built on that thesis not on the
theis any other thesis I'm gonna put
myself in a room to answer more specific
business questions for the content [ __ ]
the revenue can I ask the basic question
I talk to go back to you just what is a
tell me what a podcast is like how
Spotify like spoken bridges its
post-produced like you record either you
talking or a conversation and then you
upload it to everywhere that accepts it
which is why you know it's funny I was a
big advocate maybe you were following me
at this point of this app called anchor
that got bought by Spotify ironically
and everybody thought like I was an
investor and things that nature I just
like I just wanted to be historically
correct I wish I invested it would have
made sense but I was not really
investing at that time because it made
it super easy you could literally record
it on your phone and then hit one button
and it would have uploaded to all the
podcast platforms and I still think
that's how it works
or maybe they shut it down I don't know
but every day technology advances to
make [ __ ] easier
you should be hard to get on the
internet
Podcast excites me for a lot of reasons
because it's a triple arbitrage you're
making audio and if you hire a writer
you're actually quadruple arbitrage and
now you can turn it into written form
the transcription what about if you just
use this technology I'm always into it
everybody everybody everybody when they
kind of you know a lot of people are in
no culture right that is not true to put
a six of you you wouldn't be doing what
you're doing if you weren't into yes
culture but it's gonna Majan most people
are into no culture and the easy thing
for everybody say to me especially now
that people are becoming more aware of
me they're like easy for you Gary you
have a whole team I'm like I didn't have
a team for eight [ __ ] years
[ __ ] I have a team because I did
it for a decade which eventually gave me
leverage to have a team
I [ __ ] did every night [ __ ] did it
I used I mean I was the first version of
me to society was on Twitter outside of
my youtube wine show and it was built on
the fact that I spent seven hours a day
on Twitter replying to everybody that
was talking about wine every one of the
seven of us can go on Twitter right now
search a keyword of anything to do with
our business and literally jump into a
conversation as if we were at a Chamber
of Commerce event and biz developing
people are either not educated or just
hate the fact that the game is
predicated on quite a bit of a lot of
work you know like this dollar eighty
strategy that I put out everybody who
doesn't gets results because nobody's
replying to comments so when you do it
stands out and runs like I want to grow
my instrument I'm like I'm aware selfish
[ __ ] what about being selfless
and actually reply to the eight people
you just posted an hour ago eight
[ __ ] said something and you didn't
have the humility or foresight to reply
to them you just had the audacity to ask
why you didn't get twelve comments you
literally posted something people
literally replied and you left it's like
giving a presentation in a business
format
people asking you questions of the
president from the presentation and you
walking out of the room and going home
that's what people do every day on
Instagram and they're baffled why
they're not growing because everybody
cares about themselves and that's not
what the audience likes to feel you guys
watched me because I was bringing value
do you think there was some magic to you
starting on Twitter and being deeply
involved in one platform because I think
one of the no I think it's a talent game
I think of this about I think about this
like Deion Sanders if you're capable of
playing baseball and football you play
it so for me it wasn't that I was deeply
involved in that because I was deeply
involved in YouTube and blog and
bulletin boards which was [ __ ] OG [ __ ]
that mattered so no it's that I'm a
great communicator and love getting my
hands dirty and as patient as [ __ ] so
all that mixed into a very good formula
but you know but I also notice in the
history since I've been a professional
I've been on every arbitrage Google
AdWords ecommerce email YouTube social
media everything except one thing
there's a huge gap in my resume from
2002 to 2006 and that was the blog era
remember blogs exploded because I didn't
have infrastructure around me and
because I can't write for [ __ ] I just
had to sit there frustrated as [ __ ] and
watch it pass me I would had the number
one blog in wine in 2004 I knew it was
happening there's nothing that's gonna
happen in consumer behavior in
communication that I'll ever miss until
day I die and now the reason I built the
machine is to always be able to take
advantage of it but I missed like it's a
fun thing you know I've never I don't
think I've been really I said this out
loud either it's the one gap in my
resume I couldn't write self-awareness
do you feel like focus is a challenge
for small businesses because
you go to a thing like this I think I
think one no I don't think focus is a
challenge I think people not mapping
their execution to their ambition I
don't think it's focused I think it's
excuses
I think people talk a big game that they
want to build a hundred million dollar
company
but aren't willing to do the sacrifices
nor should they if one isn't passionate
enough or happy enough to sacrifice golf
or family time or leisure then they
shouldn't but I think it's I think focus
is I'm running out of time or focus is
the great entrepreneurial excuse for my
actions don't match my ambitions I think
we need a huge culture of I want to
build a four hundred thousand dollar
business I think the number one thing
that will lead to them so much more
happiness in our society is people
raising their hand and saying I'm gonna
build a four hundred eighty thousand
dollar business meaning net profit I'm
gonna do a million in revenue five
twenty expenses and I'm gonna [ __ ]
love life I want that so you know I
think people are so confused by what at
times what I'm actually saying I want to
buy the New York Jets most people should
not or do not or you know or don't so
I'd know I don't think it's focus
I think people actually don't want to
put in the hour of work in replying to
their DMS because they're not hungry
enough because it doesn't making them
happy enough and that's super okay but
right now entrepreneurship is in the
same place that college was 20 years ago
where everybody has to get a degree
right now everybody has to build a huge
business which is counter to what the
internet allows which is the Internet's
the greatest place to build small
businesses it's got it so I think and
that's why I push like this is how it
this is how my content evolved my twenty
twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen content
was very tactical because I don't want
to be a motivational speaker but then
like being deeply in making this content
I started looking at the comments
listening and like [ __ ] this is a mental
game this is people's frameworks of how
they see things you have to put yourself
in ready back to looping it all the way
back we have to put you in a position
that you enjoy the process that
lends itself to the biggest output of
content so instead of a podcast maybe
you're doing a pro bono event for
organizations for female employees
always but what you're really doing is
filming it I publicly speak for two
reasons I enjoy it like genuinely enjoy
it and it's unbelievably effective for
top of the funnel creative for me for
things that I'm trying to aspire to do
number three is it's a fuckload of money
for an hour speech you know you know
when you say your default is the hustle
part I find that that's my default as
well that I can handle and grow
something by sheer welt yeah and then as
things grow and give a few more runs and
the things are bigger then you almost
have to trust other people and things
don't grow the same pace and you wish
you wish that you were all in on one
thing but you actually can't take your
eye off the ball and other stuff so you
can't go all-in as you did at the very
start because you're trying to win games
31 to 27 and I'm trying to win games 210
to 209 okay long again it's not long
it's not longer it's that I don't care
about at the fact that anybody who
touches it besides me is doing it at a
60 to 70 percent version of me because I
don't get the judge for the customer
owners overreact on the customers behalf
just got it just cuz you know what you
would have done if you did it I don't
have to have my client feel the Delta
between what I would do versus what
sanin would do I need them to feel what
the difference is between soon on and
any other agency would do and owners get
[ __ ] up and think about the difference
between them and their employees which
is why they all micromanage which is why
they don't build big businesses
it's cool right you know I got you know
it's funny you know it's funny I'm
having a moment with myself right now
here's what happened my dad is so the
polar opposite of me that I got to grow
up and and I was so different naturally
that I actually got to watch both ways
play out in extremes
my dad's two highest-paid employees for
the entire course of him running the
liquor store worked the register because
he didn't want people to steal my cousin
and the most senior other employee were
the cashiers there were literally
customers walking on the floor looking
for help you could have gotten much more
percentage of their wallet and he didn't
want that he wanted them at the register
because he played defense against
stealing got it that's why you're in
that framework that's your perspective
you're fearing that you don't know what
Karen's gonna do with it and thus you
may lose it so you're going there what
I'm doing is getting to more knowing
that Karen's gonna keep it five to nine
out of ten times anyway I couldn't get
those two if I'm sitting here making
sure Karen doesn't lose it that's what
this promise you that's what it is and
then what what that help what I'm good
at is getting better at picking the
Karen's Karen sucks Rick Rick sucks
Susan Susan sucks Sally Jamal Kaneesha
wa suki nada
but since we don't think that you know
many people have different stars and
different way to skin a cat kind of your
way is the hustle away excuse those
words but it's it's about getting your
hands dirty and even if they're talented
individuals and you can trust them and
you need big teams to grow you know
because other companies go with VC or
partnerships or different stuff like if
you're Deena grass roots organically
that at some point you have to get you
have to be involved in at some point
that spirit and not tenacity needs to be
there journeys have a part of you in it
I have 900 employees in Singapore London
and Los Angeles in New York I understand
yeah I do not feel that doesn't have me
in it
meanwhile the entire company's out of
here at 6 p.m.
except my team I don't require my
employees to live the same framework I
live that's the other that was the other
I mean we're getting very meta with dad
today I just it's another thing that
just popped in my mind my dad would
spend all his time complaining about
employees not doing it his way I'm like
why don't you make them your partner if
they're your equal partner in your
liquor store they'll probably work as
hard as you you're paying them 605 an
hour owners are audacious so it's you're
either you're either losing and that's
what I believe
leaving opportunity on the table out of
audacity or ideology both are bad you
know
so was that ever struggle for you nope
but like but - what her - your first
person that started to help first hire
it was like okay I need to do this and
you were able to kind of turn well
you're talking about from a Content
standpoint for me as a personal brand
yes I never gave it up
I still post everything like the like
back to not having grammar skills when I
write a little bit on Instagram post you
can sniff it out you know so I don't
make it there in post-production but I
just titled
the post that's going up in an hour and
24 minutes I just literally walked by
danya's up desk watched the king botch
question thought about what I want to
say and actually titled it that doesn't
mean I won't let them title - but the
posting I'll do and the copy I write but
that's why we created Team Gary Vee
accounts it's me nobody believes it's me
because it's devastating when you think
about your like the amount of people
that the people that follow me have some
version of not wanting to be like me but
are living similar life's and they're
saying for themselves
alright he's running a thousand person
company like they're looking at
everything and they're like and they're
running a six person company and they're
not posting on their behalf they can't
even begin to start the process of
thinking it's me but I value the
trenches and people value the ivory
towers and that is why nobody scares me
but also that's probably why your
content is so Norman is because it's
authentically you 100% 100% and that's
what's different is so the end we
believe us and I know what I'm talking
about like if you really like look at
the landscape people are pontificating
for the sake of being a motivational
speaker or a thought leader this is why
I'm so bullish on you you actually have
the skills if tomorrow I started a wine
only program I would be the biggest in
five minutes if I was not me I have the
knowledge you know like I would be a top
5 sportscaster in our society right now
if I started I know a lot about sports
and I know how the framework works
I'd be bigger than Steven Naismith I
promise it wouldn't even take me that
long Steven a hundred percent that's
that's a compliment to Steven a that I
use him as the as the context but he
wouldn't win but yeah yeah that's a
compliment but like there's the audacity
is very high in my body and I would
deliver because I know the consumer and
I know how to get the awareness
stores physical your own or selling
wholesale are how many we have five
right now and what we've been doing is
we've been able to get like percentage
of sales deals and so as Real Estate's
fuck-faced Fox I love it I love it uh
you know back to like underpriced
attention everyone [ __ ] on real
retail and I think this is gonna be a
golden era for retail you're dead in
retail if you sign you're at least six
years ago and have fourteen years to go
if you're buying real estate today
there's some arbitrage yep good and I've
been working the store so I've been love
it learning a lot and I think what's
missing is the story that I've seen
developed from my dad from 2010 to 2012
out of clothing without leaving yeah
without really understanding that it's
hard it you know train your you if you
do your best to train your sales
associates on the store you should tell
the stories before they walk in and
after they walk in and not rely on it
being in the store it should be a part
of it right but your control from the
top is extraordinary right and that's
what I'm I want to do here is I really
want to show where the value of the
business are and I think you know what
my dad values and something we were
talking about recently was he said he's
like I don't really care about making
money I just want to express my
creativity and create a great product I
understand I want that too you know I'm
when everyone in the business to know
that I want every customer you know that
listen I have had a really intriguing
time with myself in the last year of
realizing how much money is unbelievably
not interesting to me so I understand
that and believe it could be true I like
it as a competitor cuz it's a scoring
mechanism obviously I wanna buy the Jets
and realize I'm not gonna win it on car
I'm not gonna buy him on Karma but I get
it yeah happiness happiness that was the
whole idea was he saw what the crap your
companies were doing to the bigger
and you want to do the same thing at the
peril and by the way and by the way why
stories and contextual stories and
contemporary stories matter
against all odds some of the stuff we're
doing with Budweiser around actually
telling stories whether women's world
cup or ghee Wade this is why big
companies when Goliath starts
understanding how to act like David good
[ __ ] can happen for Goliath yes sir my
guess my question is I wouldn't be able
to convey that and I want to thinking
about where to start whether I mean I'm
hearing podcasts a lot podcast YouTube I
mean this is super like it's literally
just a game of starting yeah I mean you
can get into the weeds of like paid ads
and all that something I think I really
want to just nail the story first you
get that out there but I'll got some
good news the story is a piece of cake
it Act you're not correct you're not
you're not Vince McMahon and Walt Disney
you have a literal actual story it's why
mine so easy I sold lemonade
I sold baseball cards I bagged ice like
it's not like I didn't have to think
about it what was your dad thinking in
2007 that led him to 2010 like you can
do this in perpetuity
what happened 1979 you know like you can
do this in perpetuity so you're
overthinking it just tell it just tell
it like to take your [ __ ] phone and
stick in your dad's face and then talk
and post it yeah and then read the
comments and be like glue people like
that part bottom up everyone's top down
I don't like I'm gonna figure it out and
they're gonna like it I'm like I have no
[ __ ] idea I'm gonna watch what they
like got it
just [ __ ] post
I mean I literally look like a hostage
in the Middle East in like my [ __ ]
first wine library TV episodes like
literally I look at them like that's
like cliche 1984 hostage situation [ __ ]
for me that's like easy you know flash
however when it's not like that
I understand and that's how I kind of
came to about knowing you okay do know
me
yeah like I'll go on a rant a little bit
yeah like holy [ __ ] you're this guy yeah
like who the [ __ ] is this guy yeah and
it's for like similar reasons like I'll
I never like I'll dress regularly that
don't wanna [ __ ] what my hair looks like
most of times put a hat on is that bad I
just want to straight work hustle but
it's all post anything I don't give a
[ __ ] about Facebook okay but when it's
in like I guess in person or like this
is a little bit different that's okay
like how do you break out of practice
but when you're hustling 24/7 yeah I get
it
I didn't it still doesn't change it
still doesn't change the answer to your
question yeah yeah and why do you want
that to happen is that in real human
life or is that for business purposes so
you can be yourself versus here's my
thing this mate you know I don't know if
this is gonna liberate you but I can't
believe how much this is after working
through but practice talk talk talk
think think think
the reason I'm good in both I think or
Kotler that's not that's not a good word
comfortable in both is cuz I know that
nobody knows me all the way I don't want
you're just talking about judgment you
do know that it's just judgment and by
the way same with
I'm a tough guy on video and on stage
I'm far more passive like I'm by energy
like ask Nick acid on ask them like I'm
very passive non confrontational like
very much in real life it's just a you
know context matter so I understand how
people can be different but what you're
referring to interpersonal new
first-time networking or what have you
it's judge it's judgment you actually
value the person's judgment which I
actually understand we all have that
here's my thing on judgment they don't
have the context to be able to judge you
the reason but it's also here's what's a
very important part what people don't
understand about this is the following
the reason I can deal with people miss
judging me and plenty people do often is
because I also don't listen to people
that give me accolades the reason people
are so vulnerable to judgment is because
they thirst accolades they thirst
acclaim they get it but then when they
get negative feedback they've already
put feedback on a pedestal
I can't hear either you know
do you know flattering it feels for
somebody say they have goosebumps that
you walk into a room do you like like
just even comprehending that right now
as I say it out loud is is wild it's so
flattering I don't know what to say it's
just like remarkably flattering however
how that synthesizes through my body is
equal to somebody saying that I'm snake
oil salesman that's why I'm able to deal
with everything I just know that you
don't know who I am and I don't know who
you are
that you okay get this man out here that
won't be my legacy yes if you if this is
the greatest human organization yes its
which it's not enough like its it okay
that you do it through communications
and through advertising I do do you
think that this is a stepping stone you
say for bronzer
I think the coin I think the question
becomes for whom you know when you ask
is it okay for me you mean I assume that
would be the right set for me the I
don't buying the New York Jets as my
ambition the process of trying is my
happiness I've already won it's over
it's over there's an I don't want the
trophies
I want the process once I started
putting a lot of pieces of my life
together
I dropped the Yankees and the Rangers
when they won their championships I
stopped following them because I don't
want what most people want which is to
wear those hats and jerseys to give me
self-esteem through an outside force I
have my own self esteem I want the chase
I used to judge myself that I used to
just want girls to like me and that was
enough like I didn't understand that I
thought it was a bad person right like
you know that was just like not a night
I remember like I would talk to my mom
about it like I just want to get them to
like me I don't even want it wasn't even
about like hooking up and not talking to
them just the process of could I and it
felt like it felt bad in that format but
in real life it's actually a very good
format of happiness you're not looking
for that validation or that trophy you
just like your game I'm just so happy I
guess my question stems from the
personal branding part because for me
personally an issue
kind of in a way and that you're
actually you're an inspiration to many
for non-advertising relations yes
industries correct but actually because
of what you've done you're an
inspiration you know you go already up
there with it with the legendary
advertising figures like Overby and
those guys wait you're being very
flattering like what I don't think
people understand what I'm really up to
and you're you're you're starting to go
down that path and I don't want you to
steal my thunder so I'm jumping in i I
think I'm gonna break the whole history
of it yes I'm excited about it I'm
excited that it's not about Vayner
becoming a billion-dollar Holding Co
which it will I'm excited that 21 year
old Karen is gonna start a great shop
and never sell it to publicist the only
way you break our industry is don't let
the bankers buy up all the shops I don't
do that by building a huge company I do
that by inspiring an entire generation
of twenty year olds to build a shop and
be happy with 1.3 million kickin four
hundred thousand and enjoying their
work-life balance in the way they decide
it should be done not whatever is
politically correct at the moment
work-life balance is gonna be super
differently politically correct when the
world melts there's gonna be a different
point of view of how you should do it so
yes for sure yeah my I want to be the
greatest entrepreneur of all time
because it's a fun thing to aspire to
and it will not come in making the most
money it will come in the form of
bringing the most value to the most
entrepreneurs in the world and I think I
got a shot because I'm 43 and I'm far
along and have a lot of leverage and
momentum and having 50 [ __ ] more
years at least to do it so if I buy the
New York Jets in the following execution
I'm in perpetuity known that the Jets
come up for sale in 17 years but I have
not amassed enough money but every
entrepreneur that I've affected with
free value
sin and we buy him that's a [ __ ] good
ending to a movie feels better think
just just think about like why don't you
know sometimes I think about that and
honestly I'd prefer to do it myself at
some level but I kind of think that
that's kind of cool too and like I and
was like and the movement of like
preferred to do it myself to what I just
painted you has gone like this right
which means probably in ten years I was
like [ __ ] I'm gonna crowdsource the
whole thing right like you know um super
interesting how life actually works
I think karma is the most practical
thing on earth I really really do 100%
it was awareness of what I was up to in
the thoughtful moments of my life
there wasn't a tangible thing it wasn't
that consumed anything it was just
higher level of self-awareness it was it
was always there it's what I was always
doing I just didn't realize it so it was
really subconscious to conscious
awareness of journey over right no no
and again I'm not educated enough on how
we describe meditation like like this is
funny to say out loud
I talk to myself all the time I don't
know if I'm meditating I don't know if
that's what everybody does I don't know
what you guys are doing but like I don't
know like if I'm taking a shower or like
on a plane or like it's just very common
for me to be thinking and talking not
like hey Gary it's not that literal but
it's like I'm always thinking I'm in
tune and I'm into with myself and like
me I'm not paying attention to out it's
why I don't consume a lot I figured out
what it brings me escapism the Jets
you know I've you know there's things
that bring me escapism which I think we
all need some golf some vacation a lot
some read that's fine consuming movies
and I understand escapism that took a
while and like oh that's why I like it
you know actually that one came pretty
intuitively pretty quickly by the time I
was in my mid-20s I'm like oh that
that's a good breed but I took it very
literal I was like oh the Jets played
during the holiday season of wine
library and because it's so hard it's so
nice to have this thing on Sundays that
after working 150 hours a week from
Monday to Saturday and that was very
very literal but now it's macro right
like there's only one thing on earth
and it's the New York Jets that when I'm
in it nothing else matters
truly I literally you could tap me on
the shoulder and say the Internet has
been disabled alcohol has been banned
and we're taking your voice out of your
body and I'm like cool just let me watch
the third quarter and that's an
incredible thing to have and I wish that
on everybody and I think people have it
I think they have it I'm more I think
escapism is very good I think a lot of
people use leisure to escape their
unhappiness of their profession I think
a lot of people that's where I get kind
of worried you know are you really into
golf and movies and all the stuff
because you actually hate your 9:00 to
5:00 which is still no matter what gonna
take up a big percentage we've got
questions please yeah we're about this
is was this was a little bit I think
people are asking we he bounced I was
you know kind of like you and your dad
like he taught me to be successful to be
happy and I always argue no I want to be
happy to be successful and you know I'm
kind of a disciple of like Dan Millman
where the peaceful warrior that's kind
of what I what is that my apology it's
just it's just a way of looking at the
developing people performance and
athletics understand okay so I am
approaching my business as a startup I
haven't sold a thing yet okay is I feel
like on my own customer and I know how
advertisers are getting to me so why
don't I emulate what they're doing to
try to get to other people like me that
maybe want to follow our hearts or break
80 or become on the you know make it on
the PGA Tour and I've seen that through
Facebook funnel marketing to get you to
a website that has content then then
ten might lead to something else is I
apologize but probe I apologize my wife
texted me something I apologize go to
last part I apologize yes you're
scratching the ownage I see under said
goodbye I know how people marketed to me
and I take off advertisers every fit
post on my facebook is okay no guy just
trying to suck me into a funnel and why
buy everything why because I want to
learn about what they're doing I want to
see what the hell yeah yeah you're
coming from b2b approach more than a b a
c approach okay right think about that
right like even the fact that you're
aware that this is a funnel means you're
thinking about it more as a b2b approach
then it b2c approach and let me say it
again when you see that stuff you're
aware of that what that stuff's trying
to do to you and you're probably looking
at it to see if you can learn anything
for you to do it to somebody else okay
you're doing b2b b2c is you're just
doing it for people that actually like
golf so where you need to be careful
this is why the whole information
selling ecosystem was built like all the
stuff that I'm not as fond of which is
lowest common name there marketing like
you know is everybody's watching it
somebody higher up the pyramid to them
and buying their course or their thing
in the back of the room just to they're
actually buying it so they can do it to
somebody else
yes the outlets simple like well we can
give you the outlet there's nothing
easier than figuring out the outlet you
follow me and you watch everything I do
every day
it's the biggest tell of all time why am
I asking for your cell number for my
health because I think it's funny no
because for twenty years I understand
where the consumers going next and
texting is open for business
where you deploy at my friend you've
already figured out follow me
I'll give you all the information for
free by you watching what I'm doing well
you need to figure out is that you're
actually doing it for the end consumer
not for somebody who's then trying to
make that's the problem with that's
where those things I think that's
amazing power to do what are you selling
them in in once I understand in what
format understood so I think I think the
reality is is that as long as you're
coaching for that specific thing you're
gonna have a much better chance than
coaching them for the sake of coaching
and what you need to do in my opinion
this is where people's personal brands
get destroyed is value people value
filtering the right people who you
believe will get value versus anybody
who'll write a check I mean I can have a
50 million dollar a month mastermind at
this point I mean probably not but like
it could be real bank let you know
there's just an awfully long line of
people that want to pay me 50 thousand
dollars a month to like hang out with me
but that would lead to the quick erosion
of my brand this was hard for me in a
world where I wanted the content this
was hard a full Disney and Zappos like
ten thousand dollar thing but I was
worried that it was too close the things
I don't believe in it's why it's only an
hour of me I needed to not be that I
needed to be way more Disney and you
know be our guest Danny Meyer and Zappos
this is Vayner this is Claude
this is Vayner Nick I'm thrilled I like
I knew literally if I didn't want the
content I wouldn't do it
I'm very aware that let some less people
would sign up that's super great I leave
money on the table all the time that's
for DS so you can imagine if this right
once a lot of people try to razz me like
you you are monetizing for DS I'm like
[ __ ] if I was mind x my audience
I wouldn't do it in something that at
the end of the day you know Machop
making on the 12,000 bucks personally
once it funnels through the machine and
overhead and my partnership with Steve
Ross 80 bucks 800 bucks whatever
whatever it is I promise you it's not as
interesting as other [ __ ] I could be
doing so it's the same it's the same
reason I sell wine and sneakers if I'm
going to do anything with my community
it needs to be about passions of mine
and things they may be doing otherwise
like your if you buy
I don't want anybody who only wears
sandals to buy Mike a Swiss I want
people to consider it versus another
pair of sneakers
I don't want anybody who doesn't drink
wine to buy empathy if you're going to
BevMo or [ __ ] Total Wine and I've
brought you value I want you to sign up
for empathy not to mention the fact that
then on top of that I'm producing a $40
wine for 20 bucks you know what I mean
so that's how I think about [ __ ] you see
where I'm going it's very important
otherwise you'll just be like everybody
else and that that industry continues to
decline too many people like me giving
it away for free where are you in terms
of media it's too early I'm watching it
but I would you would you then change
your vision and go all-in on something
like that yeah I mean that's the best
world for me like when you have the
leverage you don't want anybody in the
middle to take anything
essentially what you said about
everything innocence but would it need
to relate to the division of creating a
great human organization the world's
greatest like imagine if imagine if
blockchain and your best didn't really
have as many people budget there was
robots and you were no longer the
world's greatest organization the market
is more powerful than my ambition so if
in your extreme scenario if it's robots
then it's robots like I don't have any
interest in fighting tidal waves yeah I
mean I just don't understand how people
fight against technology its undefeated
always there's nothing more corrupt than
countries printing currency you know it
you know I think what's fun about you is
like you like to get philosophical like
this can get real it you can you can
stay on this forever or it can get real
simple like it just depends on what
perspective you want to take with your
conversations you know like I mean you
could take this to the moon but like I
think where people get caught up in the
philosophical conversations of
technology advances is they move too
fast one of the things I'm most proud of
as like a micro bet in the last three or
four years is VR I mean if you look
carefully enough in my content three
four years ago two years ago four years
ago I was so on it everybody was hot
magically this VR that CES 2017 was all
about VR VC funds VR VR VR and I would
and I was yes and I was extremely loud
saying this is not close cuz I don't
guess I I bought Bitcoin in 2014
but I'm not a blockchain expert I'm not
into gold rushes I grew up in the
alcohol I owned weed library calm in
1997 I mean I've been on cannabis but
I'm not a cannabis expert I'm patient
and thoughtful and pay attention I don't
need to brand myself as an expert or
like or give me people literally that we
all know on Twitter or other things have
in the last four years been a social
media expert a blockchain expert and a
cannabis expert and there's nothing
wrong with chasing news I mean there's a
lot of quick money to be made and I
don't judge it's just not what I'm
interested in and so timing matters to
me and so for example if we're gonna go
live practical on the blockchain
conversation we got a long way to go we
also have Russia China and America to
fight you think they're gonna give it up
so fast
people are so naive about blockchain
blockchain undermines the whole thing if
blockchain wins then the only thing
countries have are weapons because if
you take away the peer-to-peer
infrastructure of currency it gets real
weird real fast whoever the [ __ ]
Illuminati are they're not about
blockchain I don't know it's really
funny like I so don't believe in it I
couldn't believe in it less I think it's
the subconscious insecurity of man and
woman that creates the Illuminati people
desperately like to think somebody else
has control
I don't accountability brother ah you
got it accountability is my Illuminati
you know yep you know how about we
actually take accountability into a play
America is deeply racist guess what
you can move you could you could I mean
I'm in America from from religious
persecution I'm a refugee being Jewish
in post-world War two Soviet Russia
meant both my grandfather's spent
significant time in jail for being
Jewish like a
I hate when people are naive we have so
many shortcomings in America but life's
about alternatives like I just don't
know like I don't know like that like I
hate so many things anything that isn't
kind and wonderful to people I'm against
it's just that like how are you gonna
boil that ocean it's back to you know
it's just like and and by the way like
people can say easy for you to say I
fully understand that cool I'll take it
easy for me to say now like then I then
it's just a comma of now what like your
happiness doesn't come on blaming you
know like like it just is what it is
like we have the Internet and honestly I
wouldn't have talked like this
pre-internet I mean it I think the
Internet is grossly underrated
I have a question for you on a separate
topic yep well earlier you talked about
breaking things and that you know like
when we were talking about the
advertising industry and you know like I
want to break this and I also want to
just basically break everything about
with himself well I really do build
technology that it seems impossible and
what advice do you have for like someone
who is tackling a similar mission tell
the truth and make content at scale it's
it it's why I like cannabis I have no
idea at all my science classes and suck
have anything to do with health
knowledge but deeply as one human being
subjective intuition I deeply believe
that cannabis cures a lot of things that
big pharma doesn't like deeply like
every ounce of my soul and I'm not a
conspiracy theorist I'm like the reverse
because my dad is such one you know but
man it feels right to me and so I like I
love that there's so much evolution of
like people that have expertise that
have thoughts and that's what the
internet does speak the truth if I
supported television advertising and
programmatic banner advertising
vaynermedia would be a billion dollar
company today
100%
I eat my own dog food well I was gonna
the make continent scale thing which is
what I think we're all here in some form
or fashion yeah
often find it challenging one I know I
get in my own way a lot cuz it's like oh
I need to be perfect I come from like
music videos yeah that's it you're ready
dead yeah any how old are you
right anybody like over 20 who ever did
producing something is in deep [ __ ] for
what I believe in
cuz the whole religion was the whole of
core subjective quality yeah subjective
right like his player which project
quality is a KC nice that many like what
what is quite like subjective quality
its when Steven Spielberg said Netflix
movies shouldn't be part of it I was I
laughed so hard inside I was like and
now he's finished
that's literally went through my mind
like literally it was insane how much by
the way when I said he's finished I
meant for one human who gets to make one
judgement me I'm like oh he's a loser
which blew me away about him because he
was really judged in the late 70s for
his film style it wasn't supposed to be
right
I hate hypocrisy when people get old
nobody is worse than the world to me
than an old old old finished
entrepreneur because she or he often
starts to use their money to change
rules it is the it is the flaw of
capitalism you love it when you're a
young lion and then you want to change
it when you're an old lion well
make me to come in earlier market don't
mark it with the intent of conversion
and I think a lot around Oh so nine ten
so forth so I guess the the struggle
conversion is assumed when you bring
value to the audience yeah I guess the
struggle is okay I got $10,000 to the
budget or fifteen or twenty or fifty or
whatever and it's like alright put an ad
on Facebook drive conversion straight
for purchases and get money in the door
or drive money you know put other
valuable content out that's a little
more indirect well knows good that
you're larger know do that okay but just
make sure it's valuable you'll find that
it will convert better when it's
valuable so what I would do is ready for
this I would take eight thousand bucks
and do the one move you've got that
works it's this video against this
audience right and I would take 2,000
bucks from that if that ten thousand and
try [ __ ] got it and then you understand
yeah I'm practical I'm not [ __ ] mother
Teresa out here by the way I can't use
mother Teresa anymore like people get
crazy I guess the conspiracy I guess
she's bad to now like it I don't [ __ ] it
was bad
yeah there's bad trust me I see the
comments I got it I haven't done the
homework yet but anyway yeah it also
seems like you placed a lot more value
on comments than metrics ever heard you
talk about any metrics is our comment
deeper comments to you the that's the
magic qualitative insights to help me
figure out where I go next value me like
I value that so much more than Matt that
shows me what worked yesterday that's
why I enemy
I'm not in the rearview mirror I
innovate lack of fear you know in that
format similar to judgment 101 like I'm
not scared to put out a put do you know
Instagram especially has just captured
so many people of a generation they
literally post to maximize likes they've
killed their own creativity people start
creative on Instagram when people start
following them and then they become a
robot of the machine because they know
it's you know attractive women young
women ask me secretly like at a
conference or at a DM of like I really
know a lot about health and wellness but
when I post that I get 4,000 likes but
when I post my ass or my boobs I get
15,000 and I can't stop and I'm like
okay how about not having yourself
esteem wrapped up and how many likes you
get on Instagram but but it becomes the
machine I thought by the way that's the
version of an attractive female than the
version of a life coach is saying
something that isn't I mean the people I
come back on a daily basis are saying
like go for the money get the car did it
you know like this is what you get if
you cut corners hot chicks and private
planes and fun and it's easy and it's
passive yes I'm the yes I'm completely
detached I'm so detached I don't even
think I'm in this room whatever comes in
your head comes out your mouth it sounds
like to me pretty much and I'm so and
I'm and and I'm so petrified of being
historically incorrect that is my North
Star and that comes in all shapes and
sizes that's why I don't guess because I
could be wrong and then that clip could
exist I don't need somebody when I'm
pontiff but when the whole world knows
who I am when I'm said and done I don't
need I don't need
from Chile raising a salmon say you
ripped me off
not interested I'm old-school bro my
reputation that I gave more than I took
I'm just a unique package for such an
altruistic ambition which is why I'm so
confusing to have somebody who has this
kind of framework that also comes in the
form of being a New Jersey immigrant who
loves competition [ __ ] with the norms
I'm not a Buddha I'm not a third
generation insecure that I had so much
money from grandpa that I'm gonna give
it back to the world I'm gonna be
selfish and selfless on tilt on both
forever
makes sense
which is why people are super thrown off
by some of my points of view it's
actually where I think our society is
gonna go I'm actually really excited I'm
like oh wait a minute I think I might be
a preview human I think what's happening
in America and the world for that matter
is left and right or getting so pulled
apart that eventually that breaks and
then we come back to the middle and I
think I'm practical optimism which means
I want cut like the thought of like
demonizing or or or winning on fear is
just completely unacceptable on the flip
side [ __ ] you and your six place
trophies like I understand we all have
dreams I'm not gonna subsidize that from
the top so it's you know like it's
almost like if I'm at a dinner party and
talking like people are so confused
they're not sure where I said you know
I'm a piece of that TV ads
the bits even on the table you know it's
there something what do you think of the
six hundred billion dollars spent on
advertising globally and the consumers
get none of it back would you would you
think that that would be a way of
blowing things up no I don't because if
I think if you look at the last two
decades of anything that looks that way
the human then becomes a person that
values their Instagram likes over actual
value if we incentivize people to watch
commercials everyone loses it's a great
ideology go read go read mark ISM go
read it
everybody in this room if they read the
seed to communism would love it some
things are good on paper it sounds great
to share the money with the person that
watches the commercial until we realize
what happens in the subconscious but is
there going to reward and produce thing
yes delivering value for what you paid
for it
Facebook destructed a lot they took a
victim of bad at our house oh as in so I
didn't know where they get sixty billion
dollars of advertising I say
hypersensitive but so did television
from radio so but you like what you'd
like to do with Facebook did me yeah no
I don't build platforms to amass wealth
I like I don't build highways I like
being the best Tollbooth collector got
it
I don't creams that's a level above me
and a different skill set I'm just the
best player I don't want to vet baseball
I just want to be Babe Ruth makes sense
I only speak in [ __ ] analogies it's
so ridiculous like I'm like sitting here
I'm like it's so weird it's just like
the way it make you know it's so funny
like live and like men of course I did
well on Twitter everybody sat and looked
at that thing and said 140 characters I
don't even know how to start like like
everyone was crippled in 2007 and I was
like thank God
and then emojis came and we started not
caring about spelling and autocorrect
I'm like oh my god I'm back like
literally that's what that's actually
what happened that's actually what
happened I said so maybe this is
interesting to other people too um so
you know each of us have our own
companies but also we're here talking
about our own personal brand and how you
know as you're creating all this content
and I know you have legible channels how
do you differentiate between like what
is the content you're creating for your
company versus the company the the
content you're creating for your
personal brand and where's the
intersection and the diversion between
the two the intersection diversion I
leave to serendipity I don't know think
it I don't even know who's creating
vaynermedia's content I'm sure
somebody's currently assigned which is
probably the 37th attempt at it I just
focus on what I'm doing so all of your
content you create goes just on your
personal pages that's right okay
that's right yeah I mean I'm so
intertwined with my business that the
collateral sawdust of what I'm doing
we'll always be far more effective than
vaynermedia zone content strategy I
believe
while I'm operational I promise you when
I buy Puma tomorrow probably the first
and only thing I'll do about vaynermedia
is the content strategy because the
collateral changes a little bit this
room is so far away from producing
enough of the content they need to be
producing that I don't even worry about
that people ask me like I've gotten into
so much parenting content that like I
get some fun stuff and they're like Gary
my daughter's 3 I'm really thinking
about when she's 18 I'm like bro I'm
like let's worry about 4 that's how I
think about it there's so much more to
be done right now still on that then I'm
not just even worried about it you know
it's funny I spend a lot of time which
is why it's so fun to talk with you on
the super up here which is where you're
at and then super down here and nothing
in the middle right I have the macro
thesis of what I think human beings are
doing with technology advances and
that's it and then I'm spending all my
time on execution and my new show and I
think everybody's in the middle they're
not being thoughtful enough about the
macro and they're not making this is one
everyone's just not making I don't know
what to say you're not making enough
thank you guys so much yeah